welcome back to the morning toast we are
so excited to have fashion designer
icon and now author norma kamali on the
show
welcome norma thank you for being here
it's my pleasure
i love being here we are such big fans
yeah jackie's hoping you're going to
notice that she's wearing
i noticed i saw i love it so much i have
the matching pants too but you know my
quarantine 15. it just
it couldn't work today i know but the
color is great with your hair
it looks pink really thank you so much
your clothing is
everything of the sort that's a phrase
that we love here at the morning toast
and so we are so excited to be talking
to you and so excited that you have
written a book called i
am invincible yes i have
and um i'm happy to say
um with my 75 years
of experience i decided to put a
handbook together
and i wish i had a handbook when i was
going through my 20s 30s 40s 50s 60s
and um and so basically
it's really a handbook on
how to get through the decades what uh
what to expect obviously uh
30 is very significant 20 is significant
40 you know you reach a plateau and you
monetize where you're at
and then 50 is reinvention and it
and and it's good to have a sense of
what that
means so not that you're going to avoid
the experience because the experience is
the transition that takes you to the
next place
but um but it it helps you
keep in mind that you're not the only
one that's going through that
and that it is part of the evolution
of a woman to have those experiences
now i'm sure many points in your career
you've been had the opportunity to write
a book if you wanted to because you've
been so successful for so long
so why now and why this particular book
i think now because like i said
purpose is really important and
even for you guys you're young but
having a sense of what your purpose is
in this lifetime
helps you make decisions that are the
right decisions for you instead of
meandering along and
letting life happen you'll decide
on on important things in your life
based on
how you see your purpose for this
lifetime so
i recognized early on that my purpose
was to serve women
and to um share
my experiences so this especially at
this point where i have so much
to share and i also talk about aging
with power
when i turned 20 um my mother said happy
birthday it's all downhill from here and
i started crying
and i said i don't want to be as old as
you are
and no and but we all
go through that we all recognize that
we're going to age
when we're not teenagers and we're going
to start aging and then
everybody thinks of it in such a
horrible way and
fashion and the beauty media
uh keep telling us about anti-aging
anti-wrinkle
anti-everything that has to do with
something that i quite frankly am
very comfortable with saying i'm 75 and
i am 75 and i've written a book i have
furniture line coming out my
scent is coming out in september i have
like a lot of things i'm working on
and i'm very inspired i wouldn't want to
be 20 again
i wouldn't want to be 30 40 50 ever
again
i did that and so i'm experiencing
this part of my life and if you think
about
the three pillars of a healthy lifestyle
which is sleep diet and exercise
those are the tools that help you
get through each of the decades and feel
good about your age feel good about your
body feel good about
wanting to make love because you feel
good in your body
those are things you should think about
every decade but if you think about it
at 75
you can you can enjoy
all kinds of things in life so
you worked on this book for quite a bit
and now that it's out it's been out for
like
two weeks what is the reception been
like because i'm sure it's pretty
personal
and then once you put it out there
having people read it accept it reject
it what has the feedback been and how
has that been for you
well as you know because you have a book
and and
congrats that's it um
as you know it's like giving birth in a
way you know you work on
it you you really want it to
be equality and you want to feel good
about it you want there to be
an experience that people have with it
and
it's wonderful when you actually see
that what you work so hard on actually
is getting that reception and
because the book is really written for
for a 20 year old because that's when
you get
the most out of it when you start and
you think about all these things
at 20 um you get that much more
out of the the book and the experience
and then
if when you're 30 you read it again when
you're 40
you read it again because as you get to
that age
you then understand oh i see what's
happening
i see now what i read when i was 20
now it's real now it's a real thing
that's happening
so i see the book having
you know just hanging around your house
and being there
at times where you just pull it and say
what the hell is going on
like what the [ __ ] i'm i'm feeling
you know i'm feeling so shitty like life
is passing me by
why is that what's going on and um
and then you get grounded just by okay
i see yeah i still feel like life is
facing me by
however i understand that i need to
reconcile some stuff
at this point in my life so i think the
book
um and and i'm seeing as i talk to
20 year olds and 30 year olds in
different age groups
i have a different conversation with
each age group and i'm i'm
so happy because i think if
if you can take away one nugget
of of information that can help you in
making decisions about your life i'm
thrilled
i will feel like i did my job with this
definitely we're so excited to read the
book most of our audience
are young millennial women so what
advice would you have
for them and for us women who are
starting out finding our purposes
yeah what what would you say to us
so so what age are you guys i'm 28
i'm 26. okay so
first of all the twenties are
about going out and being on the edge of
a cliff
all the time like check
yeah i'm gonna talk to her you gotta
talk to her but she needs good to go to
a cliff
she no but she is on a cliff it's a
different cliff than you're on
that's true thank you norman so
but but this is when you
you know you get objectified by
some guy that you thought was you know
the perfect
guy for you or girl or whoever partner
for you
um it's when you
really make some embarrassing
horrific mistakes it's when [ __ ]
no but you're supposed to this is when
you're supposed to
and you just have to stay on the cliff
not go off the cliff
so that's that's good but
but if you go off the cliff and get up
again that's even better
but the point being that you learn about
yourself
in your 20s you learn about um
your relationship with
um with other people with friends with
dates with relationships with
your body with your with your whole
sense of self
and that is critical and it's an
important
experience so having a lot of new
experiences in your 20s is really
important and unfortunately with covid
when you're in lockdown it is the worst
time
and i feel i really feel
like you have to make up for this that
you can't
yes life just passed you by for a year
and
and it sucks and i i
i feel that you you have to
really live life double time
when this is over and and i mean that
from the bottom of my heart
there is there's so much you have to
experience
before you hit 30 and and don't miss out
so i think if you and your listeners
you really keep that in mind that you
need to
interact with each other a lot
do less technology and more touching and
interacting physically with each other
and i'm talking
about hugging and girlfriends hanging
all over each other and brushing each
other's hair
and touching boys that you don't even
love but you just just having no i'm
very serious
but really having that in the 70s
we did that we just touched each other a
lot we were hugging and kissing each
other a lot
we didn't have technology it didn't
interfere with that and having when you
feel through your body through your
hands
when you touch a guy's face that you may
not
be in love with but you just feel
empathy
or sympathetic or you feel
something for him and he feels your hand
on his face
or even a girlfriend or but that is
so dynamic you feel it
it affects how you feel about things
and about this human being and he or she
feels some experience from that too
don't give that up you force that to
happen
because you're all missing out on that
and you're
you're starting relationships on
technology
ending them on technology and to really
appreciate
sex you need more simple touching
and you want to really learn more and
more
about appreciating sex and your body and
what your body feels
and what somebody else feels and
sometimes just having those
interactions where it's not love it's
not i gotta marry this person
but just sometimes the simple massage
is as good as an orgasm if it's the
right
experience so i recommend
just saying for your from 20 to 30
when this is over i don't want to like
be responsible for
orgies and happening
but but i do really i do
ask you to experiment with having
picnics in the park or
like getting some wine and or grass or
whatever it is you want to do and just
like
just hang out with each other and lie
down and touch and sing and
just be with each other without the
technology
don't get a basket and say okay this is
just about us
touching and talking telling our most
intimate secrets really digging deep
into the emotion
and the physical and i think you need to
to do it big time especially after
covert
and i think once you start having those
experiences and they're very addictive
and you're not one
you won't want to give them up you
really don't want to do more
of it definitely i think people are
maxed out on technology this year
yeah i'm looking forward to experiencing
new sensations once
we can once we can so i think that's
really good advice i think that's
wonderful advice i feel like very
inspirational to double down on nothing
like once we can let's go to vegas i was
ready to just like watch this like call
this your watch like right but no we
have to make up for this year i think
that's
great advice to give all of our
listeners yeah um
before we let you go we wanted to get
your temperature on you know the
happenings in the fashion world i feel
like
kobet has definitely been uh put
everyone on pause in their fashionable
you know i'm just really you know
walking the earth and leggings
and sweatpants and our own merchandise
shopboardingtoast.com
so what are you seeing now like this
loungewear does it like i feel like
a lot of people don't like it are you
into the lounge where you know the
comfortable elegance
well you know to me everything i do has
to be comfortable
if i make an evening gown you could you
should be able to go swimming in it
i like for me it has to i'm
ice i'm a big very physical active
person
so nothing gets dry cleaned i don't
believe in
you know it's like a pet that you keep
feeding why should you have a piece of
clothing that you have to keep dry
cleaning like that jacket you have on
you can wash
so yes so
so for me it's it's
always about feeling good and close that
they should make you happy
you should feel great in them you should
walk a certain way in them because you
feel that way
but they also have to be super
comfortable so
all of my clothes no matter how
extreme they are they're not they're not
meant to
be precious so the the comfort part of
it is fine
but i think there's a good question
about what's happening
with fashion and the fashion industry so
all of us have an imprint
in our brain that's never going to go
away it's the covet imprint
we will remember this you will be 95
and saying remember when
and it will be a real memory and it will
impact a lot of your decisions about
a lot of things and one of the things
we've all experienced is either you're
not wearing shoes you're wearing slides
you're wearing sneakers
you're like i visit my shoes i love my
shoes i've collected shoes
since the 60s and i take care of them
and i wear
them and now i look at them and i say
girls you're all gorgeous i think you're
fabulous but i'm not that quick
to put you on my feet because i am my
feet are in such good shape now
because they haven't been squashed in
pointy shoes they aren't like
they're really good i mean i could use a
good pedicure
but they're in good shape they're
basically
in good shape and i feel so comfortable
that i think shoes will be very
different and the kinds of shoes we wear
at different times are going to be very
different and
i think there's an evolution there the
other evolution
i feel is that
in the 70s new york city
was bankrupt it was a dangerous city
people were leaving it by the droves
uh people there weren't enough people
who had money to pay taxes because they
all left
the services in the city fell apart
there were strikes there was violence
there was
danger and it sounds
a little bit like like
something we might know right now a
little bit
yeah and so as a result
the city became incredibly
affordable for young creative types
who said you know what we'll be fine
we'll deal with the violence we'll deal
with all of this
and there was a creative culture
that started and new york city in the
70s
probably was one of the most creative
times
for the country and affected the world
and that's when the fashion industry the
american
fashion industry really began where
halston
calvin ralph everybody started labels
and i had i was in a big push in the
beginning of my career too
and the creativity was extraordinary
and it was a time where nobody
wanted to look anything like anybody
else
the last thing in the world you would
want is to have
the same bracelet the same dress
the same shoes anything but
you would find these one-of-a-kind
special pieces
and you'd mix it up in your wardrobe you
would look you would do
everything to create sort of this piece
of art
that you were every time you dressed and
the more different you look from
everyone
the more you were expressing yourself
like a piece of art so millennials
don't really think that way millennials
have a different mindset
about fashion completely so
it's not going to be an easy if that's
not a natural
thing for you to do but what i do think
you guys will be doing is you will be
thinking more
about sustainability and
the quality of what you're buying and
the longevity of it in your wardrobe
especially as you get towards 30
and then i want to say one thing about
30
30 is huge
30 is one of the biggest transitions of
all the decades
it's a hard one it's a little bit of a
slap in the face
and an awakening and you will shed some
tears
on your pillow oh no that's me
and that's okay that's okay because
everybody is going through that but
everybody has a different timeline
so i'm i
i found my soulmate at 65.
wow and in 1970 when i was 25
an astrologer told me that i would meet
my soulmate when i was 65 and i wanted
to have her killed
boyfriend i said
too like i'm sorry you cannot be right
and unfortunately she was right i met
guys i dated them but
you know as i look back they weren't
exactly
you know people that you would want to
spend your life with
so everybody has a different timeline
i'm not saying your timeline is 65
but don't don't let
this chronological
mystical timeline that was developed
century
i mean millennials ago be
the timeline for you it is not your
milestone
it's somebody else's milestone so you
have to be sure that you
attract the man or the woman or the
person you deserve
and nothing less than that and so you
have to work on yourself
to make sure that you love yourself and
you have self-respect so you draw that
to you
and you have to be sure that it is that
person
and you can have a good time in the
process it doesn't mean you can't
meet people and do things but don't
don't be frightened by
31 when you all of a sudden are
up you're in the age group
where you're aged out of the dating
market because you're not
that's you know maybe on certain dating
apps you are
but you're not and so but getting
through the way you get through 30 will
define
how you get through all of these
transitions for the rest of your life
and this is really good advice honestly
that's something a lot of people needed
to hear myself included
so thank you so much and really thank
you for being here congratulations on
your book everyone go pick it up
anywhere you get books
it's called i am invincible thank you
for being here it was awesome
a huge honor to speak to you and thank
you guys for listening
and we will see you tomorrow bye